From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
Hi. I'm John Brown.
In this edition of the
BARD Mobile How-To Series,
we are going to cover
adjusting the font and contrast.
From the settings tab in BARD
Mobile, select Visual settings.
To adjust the font
size, tap Font size.
BARD Mobile will present you with
the following options: small,
medium, large, and extra large.
On the iPhone and iPod touch, small
is 12 point type; medium is 18,
large is 24, and extra large is 30.
On the iPad, small
is 16; medium is 24;
large is 32; and extra large is 40.
Tap the desired size.
Note that the default
is set to medium.
To adjust the contrast, go to
the settings tab in BARD Mobile.
From there, select Visual
settings, then contrast.
BARD Mobile will present you
with the following options:
black text on a white background,
white text on a black background,
black text on a yellow background,
or yellow text on a
black background.
Tap the desired contrast.
Note that the default is set to
black text on a white background.
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.